Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. old silicon valley really was the wild west valleyites stole one another's product designs one another's wives and one another's employees they fought to the death all day and went out drinking together at night and deals that would one day be worth billions were often made with a handshake. That was Michael S. Malone in The Big Score, the billion-dollar story of Silicon Valley, which he wrote in 1985. Dominic, since 1985, Silicon Valley has gone from strength to strength. all may say that it's probably, in terms of today's economy, culture, civilization, probably the single most important place on the face of the planet.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听权限，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。古老的硅谷曾经真的是荒野西部，硅谷人会偷走彼此的产品设计、彼此的妻子以及彼此的员工，他们整天打得你死我活，晚上却一起出去喝酒，而那些日后价值连城的交易往往只需握手即可达成。迈克尔·S·马洛内（Michael S. Malone）在他的著作《大胜》（The Big Score: The Billion-Dollar Story of Silicon Valley）中如是说，这本书写于1985年。多米尼克，自1985年以来，硅谷可以说是蒸蒸日上。所有人都会说，就当今的经济、文化、文明而言，它可能可以说是地球上面积最小、却最重要的单一地方。
Yeah, I think you can say it's probably the most important place in our lifetimes. So 1985 was the year that Max Zorin, the villain in A View to a Kill, tried to destroy Silicon Valley to give himself control over the world's silicon chip sort of industry and that was the first time I was ever going to the Bond film was was ever aware of Silicon Valley and obviously since then you know in our working lives the way we interact with I mean the fact that we're Tom we're doing this you know we do all our podcasts yes you know on zoom listeners may imagine that we're meeting up and doing this in a studio we're not yeah i've never i've never seen tom holland in the flesh yeah but no so this is a massive world historical phenomenon isn't it and absolutely worth discussing an industry podcast i think um yes complete well so we did an episode on california and we kind of touched on on the development of silicon valley there but i think
对，我想你可以说它可能是我们一生中最重要的一个地方。所以1985年，正是《雷霆杀机》（A View to a Kill）中的大反派马克斯·佐林（Max Zorin）试图摧毁硅谷，以让自己掌控全球硅芯片产业的那一年；这也是我第一次通过这部007电影开始了解硅谷。显然，自那以后，你知道的，在我们日常的工作生活中，我们与……我是说，我们能这样交流，Tom，我们做这一切，你知道，我们的所有播客，是的，你知道的，都是在Zoom上进行的。听众可能会以为我们是在某个录音室里见面并完成录制的，其实并不是。对，我从未，我从未在现实中见过汤姆·霍兰德。是的，没有。所以，这是一个极其宏大的世界历史现象，不是吗？绝对值得探讨。一个关于行业的播客，我想，嗯，完全没错。所以我们做过一期关于加州的节目，当时我们稍微涉及了硅谷的发展，但我觉得
this is a subject that needs a much much closer closer focus. So in today's episode, we want to look at the history of Silicon Valley. Why did it, how did it begin? Why there? Where's it going? And we are hugely privileged to have had talking about this, one of the most influential figures in the development of the internet. So basically it's, it's like talking to Isambard, Kingdom Brunel about the industrial revolution. And our guest was Mark Andreessen. We talked to him a couple of weeks ago. Do you want to big him up?
这个主题需要更深入、更聚焦的关注。所以在今天的节目中，我们想探讨硅谷的历史。它为什么会这样？它是如何开始的？为什么偏偏是那里？它将走向何方？我们极其荣幸地请到了互联网发展史上最具影响力的人物之一来谈论这个话题。所以基本上，这就像是跟伊桑巴德·金德姆·布鲁内尔（Isambard Kingdom Brunel）谈论工业革命一样。我们的嘉宾是马克·安德森（Mark Andreessen）。我们在几周前和他进行了交谈。你想隆重介绍一下他吗？
I mean, Mark is a, Mark was, it was bizarre that we even got him to come on the podcast because he's far more too important to waste his time talking to people like us, but clearly not. So Mark Andreessen is best known because he basically is one of the founding fathers of the very first internet browser.
我的意思是，马克是个……马克，能请到他来上我们的播客简直不可思议，因为他太重要了，根本不应该把时间浪费在和我们这样的人聊天上，但显然他还是来了。所以，马克·安德森最为人所知的原因，是因为他基本上是初代互联网浏览器的创始之父之一。
So that was something called Mosaic, which became Netscape. Lots of older listeners will remember having used it. But also he's then dabbled in almost every single aspect of, I mean, dabbled is the wrong word, been involved with almost every single aspect of the internet. And Facebook, he's on the board of Facebook, Twitter, Pinterest, Skype, Airbnb. I think he was on the board of eBay. He was involved with PayPal. So in other words, basically everything you use on a daily basis has mark anderson's um fingerprints all over it but also also a great i mean a great thinker so not just an investor in the internet everything but but thinking about where it's going
那是一个叫做Mosaic（马赛克）的东西，后来演变成了Netscape（网景）。很多老听友都会记得曾经使用过它。但不仅如此，他还涉足了几乎互联网的每一个领域——我是说“涉足”这个词用得不对——是参与了互联网几乎每一个单一领域的建设。比如Facebook，他是Facebook的董事会成员；还有Twitter、Pinterest、Skype、Airbnb。我想他还曾是eBay的董事会成员；他参与了PayPal的创立。换句话说，基本上你日常使用的所有东西，都有马克·安德森的印记。但他同时也是一位伟大的思想家——不仅仅是一个投资互联网万物的投资人，更是在思考互联网将走向何方。
i mean i guess you have to be you're not going to make money unless you're thinking about it but i mean he's kind of really interested in placing it in the the broadest historical context so it was it was slightly nerve-wracking wasn't it to meet to meet this titan of the internet via via zoom yeah basically our internet skills had to be on tip-top form absolutely but um bless him he he came on and was um well i think i mean listen listen to this episode first billionaire guest i think i don't think i don't think jonathan wilson's a billionaire i don't think ted valence is a billionaire but mark andrewson definitely was definitely um and so we kick things off by asking him the very obvious question would he agree with us that um the development of the internet is something of world
我的意思是，我想你必须这样，如果你不思考，你就赚不到钱。但我的意思是，他真的很热衷于将它置于最宏大的历史背景中去考量。所以，通过Zoom去见这位互联网巨头，其实是有点让人紧张的，不是吗？是的，基本上我们的互联网技能得保持在巅峰状态才行。绝对是的。不过，谢天谢地，他应邀出席了……我想，听听这一期节目吧。这是我们的第一位亿万富翁嘉宾，我想。我觉得乔纳森·威尔逊（Jonathan Wilson）不是亿万富翁，泰德·维兰斯（Ted Valence）也不是亿万富翁，但马克·安德森绝对是，绝对是的。所以我们开门见山地问了他一个显而易见的问题：他是否认同我们的观点，即互联网的发展具有某种世界历史意义？
historical significance? Yeah, well, first of all, thanks for having me. Long time listener, first time caller. So as you read the quote from my friend, Michael Malone, who I've known for a long time, and I'm just a huge fan of, and I really recommend his book, The Big Spore, which just reissued by Stripe Press. I really recommend everybody read it. But as you read the quote, I actually remember he probably talks in the book. The bar that all the chip guys that he talks about in the 60s and 70s would go to every night was called the Wagon Wheel, which was an old Western bar in Mountain View. And when we opened up shop for our company Netscape in 1994 in Mountain View,
对，首先，谢谢你们邀请我。我是老听众，第一次发言。正如你读到的我朋友迈克尔·马洛内（Michael Malone）的那段引言——我和他认识很久了，我是他的超级粉丝，我极力推荐他的书《大胜》（The Big Score），该书最近由Stripe Press再版了，我强烈建议每个人都读一读。但正如你所引用的，我其实记得他在书中可能提到过，他在书中谈到的那些在60年代和70年代每天晚上都会去的酒吧名叫“马车轮”（The Wagon Wheel），那是山景城（Mountain View）的一家老西部风格的酒吧。当我们在1994年在山景城为我们的公司网景（Netscape）开张时，
guess what bar we would go to at the end of every night? The Wagon Wheel. Wagon Wheel. So it's sitting in this sort of increasingly, you know, kind of run down, you know, quite literally like Old West themed bar. And so the, you know, the symbolism symbolism uh runs deep for sure well the fact it's the wagon wheel and that in a way california is the kind of the end of the journey isn't it uh i mean do you think is is silicon valley a kind of a continuation of the american frontier
你猜我们每天晚上结束工作后会去哪个酒吧？“马车轮”。马车轮。所以，身处这样一家日益显得……你知道的，有点破旧的，字面意义上就是老西部主题的酒吧里，那种象征意义……象征意义可以说是极其深刻的。嗯，事实上它是“马车轮”，某种程度上加州就是旅程的终点，不是吗？我的意思是，你认为硅谷是美国边疆的一种延续吗？
the idea that you have to go forwards all the time yeah so i was born and i was i was i grew up in the rural midwest you know northern wisconsin and it was always this you know there was you know just as you know i didn't have any real sense of the sort of like deep history but like you know even as a kid it's like there's this like you know sort of romance uh you know to california and you know i think there has been in you know in america for like 150 years and um and so you know upon graduating you know, in America for like 150 years. And, and so, you know, upon graduating college, I, you know, I headed West following the, the sort of, you know, the, the original trail. And of course, you know, what happens if you head West in the U S it's, you know, you, you head West until you hit the ocean and then you stop. Yeah. You know, since we, we actually
那种你必须不断向前探索的想法。对，所以我是出生并成长在农村中西部（你知道的，威斯康星州北部），那里总是有一种……就像你知道的，虽然我对深厚的历史并没有什么真正的概念，但即使作为一个孩子，也会觉得加州有一种……你知道的，某种浪漫色彩。我认为这种浪漫色彩在美国已经存在了150年了。所以，你知道的，大学毕业后，我朝着西方进发，追寻着某种……你知道的，最初的足迹。当然，你知道的，如果你在美国向西走会发生什么？那就是，你一直向西走，直到撞上大洋，然后你就停下来了。是的。你知道的，因为我们实际上
did that build up, build out the territories, you know, earlier on. And so if you go as far as you can to the West and then stop, you end up in, you know, on the coast of California and you basically end up either in, you know, the dream factories of Los Angeles, or you end up in the dream factories of the San Francisco Bay area. And, and yeah, and, you know, sort of, as I've, as I started to appreciate the history ever since, including that I'm just the latest in the long line of people who have made this trek, you know, yeah, there is a, you know, there is a, you know, the, the frontier, the frontier spirit, I think you'd have to say like lasted longest in California, you know, yeah, there is a, you know, there is a, you know, the frontier, the frontier spirit, I think you'd have to say, like, lasted longest in California. You know, the two histories are fascinating.
在早期就已经把那些领地开拓完了。所以，如果你尽可能地向西走到头然后停下来，你最终就会来到加州的海岸，基本上你最后要么会落脚在洛杉矶的梦想工厂，要么就会落脚在旧金山湾区的梦想工厂。是的，而且随着我后来开始逐渐理解这段历史，包括我只是这长串踏上这段旅程的人中的最新一员，是的，有一种……你知道的，这种边疆精神，我想你不得不说，在加州持续的时间是最长的。你知道的，这两种历史都非常迷人。
So, you know, one is the Northern California of the California gold rush. And so you literally have the land where, you know, the streets are, you know, the streets are in theory paved with gold. It's a little bit harder to take the gold out, but it's there. And then, you know, in Southern California, you have this whole other thing, which I'm also fascinated by, which is sort of the, you know, they literally like dream the city into existence, right out of the desert. And that, you know, that's a whole, that's a whole saga of its own. But then, you know, the problem with California, you know, the problem with the American frontier is like, it did stop, you hit the edge of the coast, the physical frontier did stop, and you couldn't go any further. And so you know my my my sense is yeah what's basically been happening since since that you know since the literal development of the physical frontier
所以，你知道，其中之一是北加州的加州淘金热。所以你字面意义上拥有这样一片土地，那里的街道……理论上街道是用黄金铺就的。要把黄金挖出来虽然难了一点，但它确实在那里。然后，你知道的，在南加州，你有了完全不同的另一番景象，我也对它着迷不已，那就是他们字面意义上凭空把一座城市“梦”了出来，直接从沙漠中拔地而起。而这，又是一个自成一体的传奇故事。但是，你知道，加州的问题在于……美国边疆的问题在于，它确实停下了，你撞上了海岸的边缘，真正的地理边疆确实停滞了，你无法再前进了。所以，你知道，我的直觉是，是的，自从地理边疆的字面意义上的发展停滞以来，基本上一直在发生的事情是，
um is that we have been busily you know building basically new virtual frontiers and you know of course right of course you know the internet is a is the new virtual frontier of course you know the center of the development of the internet turned out to be um you know california and if you were sort of dating this revolution if we were if we want to place it in time as well as in place when do you think it it really started so the world war ii or before that or in the 70s when when should we when should we start our story yeah so there's another friend of mine actually uh his name is steve blank um and he's a longtime valley entrepreneur himself and actually has become quite a quite a historian um his in his in his in more recent years.
我们在忙碌地……基本上是在建设新的虚拟边疆。当然啦，互联网就是那个新的虚拟边疆。当然，互联网发展的中心最终变成了……你知道的，加州。如果你要给这场革命确定一个日期，如果我们想在时间和空间上同时定位它，你认为它到底是什么时候真正开始的？是第二次世界大战之前，还是70年代？我们究竟应该把故事从什么时候开始讲起呢？对，事实上我还有另一个朋友，他的名字叫史蒂夫·布兰克（Steve Blank）。他本人也是硅谷的资深创业者，近年来实际上已经成了一位相当了不起的历史学家。
And he has this this talk you can find on YouTube, and I think it's called The Deep History of Silicon Valley. And he's he's sort of reconstructed, you know, kind of as far back as you can go. So the the typical way the story is told is that it starts basically with Hewlett Packard. So it starts with an engineering dean at Stanford named Fred Turman, who basically encouraged his, you know, young, young students, Bill and Dave, right, Bill Hewlett and Dave Packard to start Hewlett Packard. You know, they actually start Hewlett Packard in the late 1930s. They then actually put the company on ice for seven years, because they go off to fight World War Two. And so they put it in suspended animation, go fight the war, they come back, they sort of, you know, dethought, you know, in 1945, and it becomes kind of the iconic Silicon Valley company.
他有一个可以在YouTube上找到的演讲，我想它叫《硅谷的深层历史》（The Deep History of Silicon Valley）。他把能够追溯的历史尽可能地还原了。所以通常讲述这个故事的方式是，它基本上是从惠普（Hewlett Packard）开始的。也就是从斯坦福大学的一位工程学院院长弗雷德·特曼（Fred Terman）开始的，他鼓励他的年轻学生——比尔和戴夫（即比尔·休利特和戴夫·帕卡德）去创办惠普。你知道的，他们在20世纪30年代末实际创立了惠普。然后他们实际上把公司搁置了七年，因为他们去参加第二次世界大战了。所以他们让公司处于休眠状态，去打仗；战争结束后他们回来了，在1945年左右把公司“解冻”，它就成了硅谷最具代表性的公司。
So that's the typical history there. Steve argues there's actually a prehistory to it. And the prehistory actually is the development of military technology for between World War I and World War II. And so there were a series of basically advanced R&D labs in Northern California in the 1920s and 1930s that developed a lot of the key technologies around radar and around, you know, guidance systems
这就是通常的历史叙述。而史蒂夫则认为，其实在此之前还有一段前史。这段前史实际上是第一次世界大战和第二次世界大战之间军事技术的发展。因此，在20世纪20年代和30年代的北加州，有一系列基本上属于先进研发实验室的机构，它们开发了许多关于雷达、制导系统以及
and around, you know, modern aircraft, control systems for aircraft. And in fact, there's still, you know, a significant engineering presence out here for Lockheed Martin and other defense contractors,
现代飞机、飞机控制系统的核心技术。事实上，时至今日，这里依然存在着为洛克希德·马丁公司和其他国防承包商服务的庞大工程技术团队，
you know, this kind of barrier amidst the tech companies. And so he actually argues it actually predates that, actually the the actual engineering culture actually started with development of post-world war one you know his you know his argument basically was like world war one was like the first war where you know basically at least in america people were like you know okay you know technology is really going to matter like you know it's not
这种存在就夹在这些科技公司之间。所以他实际上认为，它甚至比那还要早，实际上的工程文化其实是从第一次世界大战后的发展开始的……他的观点基本上是：第一次世界大战是第一场让人们（至少在美国）觉得“好吧，科技真的很重要，飞机将发挥巨大的作用”的战争。
you know it's going to be you know aircraft are going to in particular play a huge role um and so they recruited the best and brightest to work out here so that that's the ultimate theory so you've got you've got the military and i suppose you'll say you've got hollywood to the south so you've got the idea of of creating dreams um stanford also is quite important isn't it you've got this incredible university at palo alto um and you need the brightest and the best to fuel this revolution right yeah there's a few really interesting things about stanford so you know stanford i think and you need the brightest and the best to fuel this revolution, right? Yeah, there's a few really interesting things about Stanford. So, you know, Stanford, I think generally, I think it's first of all, Stanford absolutely plays a central role.
尤其是飞机将扮演极其重要的角色，因此他们招募了最优秀、最聪明的人才来这里工作。这就是终极理论。所以你有了军方，我想你还可以说南部有好莱坞，所以你有了创造梦想的概念。斯坦福大学也相当重要，不是吗？你在帕o阿尔托拥有这样一所不可思议的大学，你需要最聪明、最优秀的人才来为这场革命提供动力，对吧？是的，关于斯坦福有几个非常有趣的地方。所以，你知道，斯坦福我认为……你需要最聪明、最优秀的人才来为这场革命提供动力，对吧？是的，关于斯坦福有几个非常有趣的地方。所以，你知道，斯坦福，我认为总的来说，首先斯坦福绝对扮演了核心角色。
It's 100 percent correct. And we could we could talk a length about that. I think there's a few interesting things about Stanford historically. You know, so one is I think, you know, it's fair to say that it's a university on par with the Ivy League, but it's technically not part of the Ivy League. And it was started much later than the universities in the Ivy League. It's a product of the 1880s, 1890s, right? So it's a product of the railroad boom and the, you know, the sort of quote unquote robber barons of that era. And you may know that the university itself was named Stanford because it's named after Leland Stanford Jr., who was the son of Leland Stanford, who was one of the main,
这是百分之百正确的，我们可以详细讨论这一点。我认为从历史上看，斯坦福有几个有趣的地方。其一是，我认为可以公平地说，它是一所与常春藤盟校不相上下的大学，但它在技术上并非常春藤盟校的一部分。而且它的创办时间比常春藤盟校的大学要晚得多。它是1880年代、1890年代的产物，对吧？所以它是铁路繁荣以及那个时代的所谓“强盗资本家”的产物。你可能知道，这所大学之所以命名为斯坦福，是因为它以小利兰·斯坦福（Leland Stanford Jr.）的名字命名，他是利兰·斯坦福的儿子，而利兰·斯坦福是美国铁路建设的主要人物之一。他的儿子不幸在16岁时夭折了。因此，他和他的妻子创办了这所大学，基本上是为了延续他们儿子的传奇。所以，这所大学可以说是第二次工业革命的产物。
you know, people who built out railroads in the U.S. His son tragically died at the age of 16. And so he and his wife, you know, started the university to basically, you know, basically carry on his son's legacy, their son's legacy. And so, you know, it's a sort of a, the university is a product of kind of the second industrial revolution. You know, it also was, of course, geographically isolated, right? It wasn't on the East Coast with the rest of the Ivy League. And then the combination of, I think, being started later and not being on the East Coast meant both that it was more insecure, but also more open minded. And then, you know, you go forward not that far, right, between whatever, let's say it was founded in its modern form around 1890. You know, it was only about, you know, 40 years until this guy I mentioned, Fred Turman, had Bill and Dave,
当然，它在地理上也处于相对隔离的状态，对吧？它不像其他常春藤盟校那样位于东海岸。其次，创办时间较晚且不在东海岸的组合，意味着它既更有不安全感，但也更加思想开放。然后，你知道的，时间没有推移多久——不管怎样，假设它以现代形式创立于1890年左右，只过了大约40年，我刚才提到的那个家伙弗雷德·特曼，就把比尔和戴夫招入他的课堂，并鼓励他们创办了自己的第一家公司。所以，它非常迅速地发展成了今天的样子。无论是过去还是现在，斯坦福与许多其他研究型大学相比，最卓越的一点在于：对于学生和教职员工利用在校园里进行的研究成果来创办公司，斯坦福采取的是非常自由放任的态度。大多数大学（包括我曾就读的伊利诺伊大学）从根本上来说，出于各种原因，都对学生或教职员工将研究成果带出校园并将其转化为商业生意的想法持敌对态度。而斯坦福一直对此持公开鼓励的态度。而且，这是一个运作得极其成功的模式。
you know, in his class there and encouraged them to start their first company. So, you know, sort of, you know, very quickly developed into what it is today. The most remarkable thing about Stanford both then and now compared to many other research universities is Stanford is very laissez-faire on allowing its both students and faculty to start companies based on the research work that they do when they're on campus. Most universities, including the one I went to, University of Illinois, are, you know, sort of intrinsically hostile to the idea that students or faculty would sort of, quote-unquote, take research off campus and turn it into a business for a variety of reasons. And Stanford has always been openly encouraging of that. And it's, you know, it's a model that's worked, you know,
所以，你知道，你必须给斯坦福记上一功，不仅因为这里孕育了硅谷的知识产权，还因为这里创造了一种精神——知识的存在就是为了用来构建产品和建立商业的，而这并不是常态。马克，从刻板印象上来看，那些在淘金热以及后来的移民潮中来到加州的人，他们大多来自中西部。他们基本上是来自农村背景的白人新教徒，渴望寻找一种新生活。
obviously just incredibly well. And so it's, you know, you have to get Stanford credit, not just for the intellectual property of the Valley, but also sort of creating this ethos that, you know, knowledge exists to be able to use to build products and build businesses, which is, which is not normal. And Mark, stereotypically, the kind of people who came to California in the kind of gold rush and then, you know, in later kind of migrations, they came from the Midwest. They were kind of, you know, white Protestants from rural backgrounds seeking a new life.
你认为，那些为了开启计算机革命而向西进发的人也是如此吗？你知道的，在30年代、40年代、50年代确实如此。顺便说一句，另一个符合这个模板的历史人物是菲洛·法恩斯沃斯（Philo Farnsworth），他被认为是彩色电视机的发明者。
Is that true, do you think, of the people who come West to sort of kickstart the computer revolution as well? You know, so it was true in the, the like 30s, 40s, 50s. And, you know, another historical figure that sort of matches the template, by the way, that you could trace is Philo Farnsworth, who was the, you know, sort of credited as sort of the inventor of color television.
他也是一个典型的例子，基本上是一个来到旧金山的来自中西部的农家男孩，并创造了科技。鲍勃·诺伊斯（Bob Noyce）在很多方面都可以说是硅谷的教父，与帕卡德并列。鲍勃·诺伊斯是英特尔的联合创始人兼首席执行官，也是50和60年代的精神领袖。你知道的，他也是一个爱荷华州的农家男孩，完全符合你所描述的特征。所以，这绝对是一个典型原型。显然，我也是其中之一——并不是要把自己和这些家伙相提并论。但我完全符合那个原型，后来我大吃一惊地发现了这一点。但是，
And he, you know, he was another classic example of like basically the Midwest farm boy who came to San Francisco and, you know, created creative technology. You know, Bob Noyce is sort of in many ways, you know, sort of the godfather of Silicon Valley, along with, you know, Packard. Bob Noyce was the co-founder and CEO of Intel and, you know, was kind of the father figure kind of through the 50s and 60s. You know, he also he was an Iowa farm boy, right, you know, right along the lines of what you described. And so, you know, that that for sure is an archetype. And obviously, I'm another one of those, not to compare myself to these guys. But I'm, you know, I fit that archetype perfectly. I discovered to my enormous shock later, later on. But, you know,
真正发生改变的是，从20世纪60年代和70年代开始，这种现象基本上呈爆发式急剧扩张，尤其是全球人才的引进。因此，特别是，我认为那里的第一个真正重大突破，就是后来被称为“匈牙利黑手党”的群体。当时你拥有了一群来自匈牙利的超级天才，他们在20世纪50年代和70年代逃离共产主义，其中有些人甚至是在步行翻越边境。他们普遍拥有高级工程学博士学位，是非常不可思议的聪明人。正是这群由盎格鲁-撒克逊新教徒（Wasps）加上匈牙利人组成的群体，创建了英特尔，并缔造了现代科技产业。安迪·格鲁夫（Andy Grove），安迪·格鲁夫可以说是美国科技界的传奇人物之一。
really, then what happened was starting in the 1960s and 1970s, the phenomenon basically just like radically expanded. And in particular, in terms of global imports of talent. And so, you know, and in particular, like I think the first really big breakthrough there was what became known later on as the Hungarian mafia, which is you had these just you had this cluster of these just super geniuses from Hungary who escaped communism, in some cases, by the way, on foot in the 1950s and 1960s. And kind of uniformly had advanced engineering PhDs, incredibly brilliant people. And they were the other sort of the wasps plus the Hungarians that basically created Intel and created the modern tech industry. And Andy Grove, you know, Andy Grove is sort of, you know, one of the legends of American technology.
他的本名叫安德拉斯·格鲁夫（Andras Grove）。他本人就来自匈牙利。他最著名的事迹是，在大概1956年的某天，躲避着坦克，步行逃出了匈牙利。所以，那是一个戏剧性的转折。当然，在此之后的几十年里，一旦移民政策在20世纪60年代真正开放，现在的这里就成了一个令人惊叹的万花筒，就像联合国一样，对吧？
His, you know, his given name was Andras Grove. He was himself from Hungary. He famously, like, walked out of Hungary on foot, you know, dodging tanks in, I think, what was it, like, 1956. And so, you know, that, that was a, that was a dramatic turn. And then of course, you know, in the, in the decade since, you know, once immigration really, you know, kind of opened up in the, I guess the 1960s you know, now it's just like, it's an, it's an amazing kaleidoscope. Like it's like the United Nations, right.
你今天走进任何一家大公司的自助餐厅，或者走进任何一家风险投资公司，看着络绎不绝的创业者，你会发现这里简直是一个令人惊叹的人才星座，其中特别聚集了来自印度和中国的巨大群体，还有大量的俄罗斯人、东欧人，
You go, you go to the cafeteria of any of these big companies, you know, today, or you go to any venture capital firm and watch the entrepreneurs going through. And it's just like, it's just this amazing, you know, constellation of talent, you know, enormous, you know, kind of, you know, kind of clusters from, you know, India and China in particular. But, you know, tons of Russians, tons of Eastern Europeans, you know,
以及越来越多的南美人、中美洲人和英国人。我正想说呢，他居然没提到英国人，这真是非常非常让人担心。对，我们需要为查尔斯·巴贝奇（Charles Babbage）和阿达·洛芙莱斯（Ada Lovelace）鸣不平。所以这里有一个惊人的事实：法国人在硅谷表现得非常出色。我们在湾区的风险投资业务有一个经验法则：每一位法国创业者都棒极了。
tons increasingly of South Americans, Central Americans, tons of, you know, Brits. I was about to say, he's not mentioning Brits, this is very, very worrying. Yeah, we need to stick up for Charles Babbage and Ada Lovelace. So here's one amazing thing. The French represent themselves very well. And so one of our rules of thumb in the valley out here in our inter-capital business is every French entrepreneur is fantastic.
他们简直是一如既往地出色。我想部分原因在于他们是法国教育体系的产物，等等。或者风投业务，每个法国创业者都很出色。他们简直是一如既往地出色。我想部分原因在于，你知道的，他们是法国教育体系等的产物。而另一部分原因当然是，他们做出了离开法国的决定。不过，这个消息太糟糕了。对，这完全违背了这个播客的精神。英国人其实也表现得挺好。
They are just uniformly fantastic. And I think part of it is they're a product of the French educational system and so forth. or edge capital businesses, every French entrepreneur is fantastic. They are just uniformly fantastic. And I think part of it is, you know, they're a product of the French educational system and so forth. And then part of it is, of course, they made the decision to leave France. This is terrible news, though. Yeah, this one is completely counter to the ethos of this podcast. The Brits are doing quite well also.
好吧，我松了一口气。我们鼓励更多的人来。欢迎随时派遣更多你们最优秀、最聪明的年轻人来。那么马克，到了70年代，你刚才提到这个山谷原本是圣克拉拉谷，长满了橘子林、果园之类的地方。到了70年代，这些全都消失了，它成了一个庞大的工业中心。我猜，要想让硅谷成为我们今天所知道的硅谷，你需要同时发展硬件和软件，而硅谷两者兼备。其中的关键硬件是个人电脑的发展，我对吗？
Well, I'm relieved. We would encourage more. Feel free to send more of your best and brightest so so mark but by the 70s uh you've said this value it's originally santa clara valley right and covered in orange groves and orchards and things uh by the 70s they've all gone it's it's this massive hub of industry and i'm guessing that for silicon valley to become the silicon valley we have now you need to develop hardware and software and silicon valley does both and the hardware the key hardware is the development of the personal computer am i right about that well so we would argue that the key hardware was the chip um right so um hence the silicon yeah hence And this is why, you know, this is why it's still
嗯，我们会认为关键硬件其实是芯片，对吧？因此……因此才叫“硅”，对吧？这就是为什么它至今仍然
called, like, you know, there are still chip companies in the Valley, you know, Intel's still here, of course, NVIDIA, you know, is probably the most innovative chip company in the world right now. And they're, you know, they're here, you know, they do all the graphics chips. So, you know, there's still a chip component. Of course, the chips aren't manufactured here. They used to be actually manufactured here. They really aren't manufactured here anymore. The fabs now exist in other places. It's too expensive to run them here, but that's still here. But it's not the central industry anymore. As you point out, software and internet broadly are the central industry now. But Silicon Valley has, of course, the iconic ring to it. But I think also, I think that name will stick
被称为……硅谷仍然有芯片公司，英特尔依然在这里，当然，NVIDIA（英伟达）可能是目前世界上最具创新力的芯片公司。他们也在这里，他们制造所有的图形芯片。所以，这里依然有芯片产业的成分。当然，芯片已经不在本地制造了。它们过去确实是在这里制造的，但现在已经不在本地制造了。芯片代工厂现在存在于其他地方，在这里运营成本太高了，但设计部门依然在这里。不过，它已经不再是核心产业了。正如你所指出的，软件和广义上的互联网现在才是核心产业。但是，硅谷当然拥有标志性的响亮名号，而且我认为这个名字将会长期保留下去，
for a long time precisely because of the central importance of the hardware, and the central importance of the chip. You know, then I would also just, you know, connect your, your thing on the PC, like, you're right about the PC, you're right about the PC as follows, I think, which is, you know, the PC was the big breakthrough that sort of took computing to the masses, right? Because, you know, computers existed for, you know, 40 years in kind of modern form before the PC hit. And so that was the big breakthrough. The PC was directly enabled by the chip. And when I say the chip, I actually mean something very specific. I mean, what's called the integrated circuit or the microprocessor. And so the big breakthrough that Intel had that made Silicon Valley possible was basically taking a lot of different kinds of components
恰恰是因为硬件的核心重要性，以及芯片的核心重要性。然后，我还要顺便把你们关于个人电脑的观点连接起来。你们对个人电脑的看法是正确的，具体原因如下：我认为个人电脑是推动计算技术走向大众的重大突破，因为在个人电脑问世之前，计算机以现代形式已经存在了40年。所以这是一个巨大的突破。个人电脑直接是由芯片赋能的。当我提到芯片时，我其实指的是非常具体的东西，指的是所谓的集成电路或微处理器。英特尔取得的使硅谷成为可能的重大突破，基本上是将许多不同种类的组件——
that would have made up a computer in like 1960. You know, many different, literally many different individual components and then literally putting them all together on a single piece of silicon, right? And then sort of the minute that happened, then all of a sudden the cost, you know, dropped dramatically to build a computer.
这些组件在1960年左右本可以用来组装一台电脑——许多不同的、字面意义上完全独立的组件，把它们字面意义上全部组合到了一块单独的硅片上。一旦这一刻发生，制造计算机的成本随之剧烈下降，
And then all of a sudden the PC became possible. You know, the PC itself, you know, dropped dramatically to build a computer. And then all of a sudden the PC became possible. You know, the PC itself, you know, the IBM PC was, you know, kind of assembled in, I think, in Florida by IBM at one of their labs. But, you know, it was basically an assembly of technologies basically clustered around the chip and then other technologies that were developed mostly in Silicon Valley. You know, Microsoft is, you know, Microsoft obviously provided the operating system for the PC.
紧接着个人电脑便成为了可能。个人电脑本身……IBM PC是由IBM在佛罗里达州的一个实验室里组装出来的。但基本上，它是围绕着芯片以及主要在硅谷开发的其它技术组合而成的技术集合体。微软为个人电脑提供了操作系统，
Microsoft was a company based in Seattle, of course. We in Northern California consider Seattle to be a colony of the Valley. I think that people in Seattle disagree. But yeah, it was really that chip that was the breakthrough. of Apple and Steve Wozniak and Steve Jobs coming together and founding Apple, putting out basically Apple I and then the Apple II. Is that a key moment in the history of Silicon Valley? I mean, that's how I think of it. Yeah, that's right. That's exactly right. So there were, and in fact, that's to complete the history, there were personal computers before the PC, right? So when we say PC, usually we now mean IBM PC or IBM compatible PC, you know, might we not consider
微软当然是一家总部位于西雅图的公司。我们北加州人一直把西雅图视为山谷的一个殖民地，我想西雅图人可能不同意这一点。但真正实现突破的，确实是那块芯片。苹果公司以及史蒂夫·沃兹尼亚克（Steve Wozniak）和史蒂夫·乔布斯（Steve Jobs）走到一起创立苹果，推出Apple I然后是Apple II。这是硅谷历史上的关键时刻吗？我是这么认为的。是的，没错。完全正确。所以，确实存在着这样的时刻。为了让历史完整，在IBM PC出现之前，其实就已经有个人电脑了。所以当我们说“PC”时，通常现在指的是IBM PC或IBM兼容PC，难道我们不应该认为
like a Microsoft Intel PC, like the reason Microsoft Intel are, you know, became the companies they did is because IBM selected them for the IBM PC, and then everybody else cloned the IBM PC architecture and created the, you know, we're called at the time PC clones, and that led to the, you know, and therefore companies today like Dell, you know, and so forth that build PCs. But before the IBM PC in 1982, and therefore companies today like Dell, you know, and so forth that build PCs. But before the IBM PC in 1982, and even before Microsoft and Intel got established to the roles that they then played in the industry, you know, the dominant roles they played, there were personal computers before the PC. And, you know, and there were, by the way, there were many different kinds of personal computers for the PC, right? There were, you know, dozens, if not hundreds of different basically consumer computers that you could buy in the late seventies, early eighties, you know, Radio Shack famously had a line, you know, that Atari, the video game company had a line,
微软-英特尔架构的PC才对吗？微软和英特尔之所以能成为今天的巨头，正是因为IBM在推出IBM PC时选择了它们，随后其他所有人都在复制IBM PC的架构，并创造了当时所谓的“PC克隆机”，这最终引领了诸如戴尔等今天制造PC的公司。但在1982年IBM PC问世之前，甚至在微软和英特尔在行业中确立其统治地位之前，个人电脑就已经存在了。而且，顺便说一下，在PC出现之前存在着许多不同种类的个人电脑。当时有几十种甚至上百种基本上是消费者可以在七十年代末、八十年代初买到的家用电脑。老牌的Radio Shack有一条产品线，视频游戏公司Atari也有一条产品线，
Texas Instruments, the kind of legendary Texas tech company had a line of PCs. And then, and then, yeah, Apple was, you know, was, was, was iconic in that era. You know, Apple, well, there's, you know, there's a rabbit hole we could go down, which is that the Valley is sort of a hybrid of like a fifties, I don't know, like a car culture, you know, conservative, sort of cultural thread that kind of came out of, and then there's like a 1960s skippy counterculture thread that Steve Jobs
传奇的得克萨斯科技公司德州仪器（Texas Instruments）也有一条PC产品线。然后，是的，苹果在那个时代具有标志性的意义。苹果……这里有一个我们可以深入探讨的“兔子洞”，那就是硅谷某种程度上是50年代的某种混合体——我不知道，比如汽车文化、保守的文化暗流；与此同时，还有一种60年代的嬉皮士反文化暗流，史蒂夫·乔布斯
came out of and Apple kind of combined those two threads. And then Steve Wozniak was kind of, you know, the engineer that pulled it together. And so, and then those guys in the 1970s, there was this phenomenon. There was this thing in the 1970s famously called the Homebrew Computer Club, the HCC. And Homebrew Computer Club, you know,
正是从这种暗流中走出来的，苹果将这两种暗流结合在了一起。而史蒂夫·沃兹尼亚克则是把这一切凝聚在一起的工程师。所以在70年代，当时出现了这样一种现象。70年代有一件著名的趣事，叫做“家酿计算机俱乐部”（Homebrew Computer Club，简称HCC）。家酿计算机俱乐部，
quite literally meant people who were building their own computers at home, which was this weird fringe hobby thing in the 1970s. And that's what Wozniak is doing. I mean, he's the best exactly there was this crowd uh of uh basically nerds um uh you know they'd have day jobs at you know hp or whatever yeah the brilliant description from michael malone of was was the kid in high school no one knew the muscleless lump with glasses everyone thought was weird but you could
字面意思就是那些在家里自己组装电脑的人。这在70年代是一个奇怪的边缘爱好圈子。而沃兹尼亚克就是其中一员。我的意思是，他确实是最典型的代表。当时有这样一群……基本上是极客。他们在惠普之类的地方有日常工作，对吧？迈克尔·马洛内对沃兹尼亚克有一个绝妙的描述：他是高中里那个默默无闻、戴着眼镜、肌肉不发达但大家都觉得有点古怪的小孩，然而
build down there anything electronic whereas steve jobs was the kind of he's the sales guy he's that he's a brilliant salesman isn't he steve jobs selling himself his brand his company and and a kind of the sense of apple as a is that right there at the beginning with apple um is that sense of apple as a as a as a lifestyle as a kind of dream of i mean that sort of sense of the frontier is very much part of apple isn't it you know made in california by apple yeah yeah exactly that that's right and then and then you know he also did you know kind of the same thing that kind of david geff did in music right at the sort of in the 60s and 70s also which is he also he kind of it it was that and then he also kind of packaged up the california ethos and to some extent the hippie ethos and sort of imbued the technology with that
他可以凭空打造出任何电子产品。而史蒂夫·乔布斯则是那种销售人员。他是个绝顶聪明的推销员，不是吗？史蒂夫·乔布斯推销他自己、他的品牌、他的公司，以及苹果给人的那种感觉……从苹果创立之初就是如此，苹果带有一种生活方式的感觉，一种梦想的感觉——我是说，这种边疆意识很大程度上构成了苹果的一部分，不是吗？“由苹果在加州制造”。是的，完全正确。然后，你知道的，他也做了一件类似于戴维·格芬（David Geffen）在60年代和70年代的音乐界所做的事情，那就是他把加州的 ethos（精神风貌）以及某种程度上的嬉皮士精神打包，并将其注入到了科技之中。
ethos. Right. And so you, you kind of, you kind of got by buying an Apple computer, you kind of got to participate in the technological future, but also the cultural future. And he put a much more consciously cultural and counter-cultural kind of element on the whole thing. Like, you know, Intel, Intel was not counter-cultural, right? Like those guys were like, it was like, you know, white, you know, white shirts, you know, white short sleeve, red shirts, black thing like you know intel intel was not countercultural right like those guys were like it was like you know white you know white shirts you know white short-sleeved dress shirts black ties you know buzz cuts um you know and then apple was like hippie central um and um you know as part of the kind of the great part of the great packaging you know part of one of the great accomplishments of american industry in the 1960s 1970s was to pack package
对。所以，当你购买一台苹果电脑时，你不仅参与了技术的未来，也参与了文化的未来。他为整件事情注入了更多有意识的文化和反文化元素。比如，英特尔并非反文化，对吧？那群人基本上是……白衬衫、白色短袖正装衬衫、红领带、黑色领带、平头……而苹果则是嬉皮士的大本营。作为美国工业在60年代和70年代的伟大成就之一，他们成功地将嬉皮士反文化运动打包并卖给了大众。
up the hippie counterculture movement and sell it to you yeah i mean i think the story of apple would be a fantastic podcast in itself, isn't it? Because it has so many kind of associations. I think back to that California podcast we did, Tom, all about the sort of the California dream and stuff. And Apple absolutely incarnates that, doesn't it? But at the same time, there's a kind of nightmarish.
是的，我的意思是，苹果的故事本身就是一个极好的播客题材，不是吗？因为它有那么多的联想。我想起了我们做过的那期加州的播客，Tom，全部关于加州梦之类的东西。苹果绝对是这种精神的化身，对吧？但与此同时，它也带有某种噩梦般的色彩。
So do you remember that? I mean, nightmarish is a weird word, but do you remember that advert? I think it was 1984 during the Super Bowl. And it was this Orwellian. So someone smash a screen or something, and the future is going to belong to the Apple Mac. And it wasn't wrong, was it? It wasn't wrong.
你还记得吗？我是说，“噩梦般的”这个词有点奇怪，但你还记得那个广告吗？我想那是1984年超级碗期间播出的。那是一个带有奥威尔色彩的广告。有人砸碎了一个屏幕什么的，而未来将属于苹果Mac。这并没有错，不是吗？确实没有错。
But I think talking of commercial breaks, the perfect opportunity to go to a commercial break ourselves. The Super Bowl had Apple. Let's see what we've got. I think we've got much better ads than Apple's had. Let's find out. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
但说到商业广告，这正是我们自己插播广告的绝佳机会。超级碗有苹果的广告，来看看我们有什么。我想我们的广告比苹果当年的要好得多。让我们拭目以待。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的八盒圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐产业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. I'm sure you'll agree that our adverts are much better than Apple's Super Bowl advert from 1984. We're here with Mark Andreessen, who's basically talking us through the history of Silicon Valley and the internet. Mark, here's something that occurs to me. Almost everybody that we've talked about, I think almost exclusively so far, has been a man.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。相信你们一定会同意，我们的广告比苹果在1984年超级碗上的广告要好得多。我们今天请到了马克·安德森，他基本上为我们梳理了硅谷和互联网的历史。马克，我注意到这样一个现象：我们迄今为止谈论过的几乎所有人，几乎无一例外，全都是男性。
And there's always been this sort of, not controversy, but there's always been this debate about how much the internet and Silicon Valley are based on a specifically masculine culture is that right do you think that's fair yeah so i was gonna say yeah there's you know this gets to be a very complex topic and of course very controversial and also let me say like there were very significant women along the way um you know some of which i've actually gotten over the years who you know played really fundamental roles uh so there's a woman named sandy kurtzig
一直以来，人们都在讨论——这算不上争议，但总有一种辩论——关于互联网和硅谷在多大程度上建立在一种特定男性化的文化之上。这是真的吗？你觉得这公平吗？是的，我想说的是……这是一个非常复杂的话题，当然也极具争议。而且我也想说，这一路上也有非常杰出的女性，其中有些人我多年来也有所了解，她们在其中发挥了极其根本的作用。比如有一位女性名叫桑迪·库尔齐格（Sandy Kurtzig）。
who was one of the creators of the software industry. There was Judy Estrin, another friend of mine, was one of the creators of the networking industry, you know, networking computers together. So, you know, for sure they existed. But yeah, for sure, the majority, you know, the majority were men. Yeah, look, there, you know, there's a component to it that's basically, you know, probably the exact same gender conversation you'd have in kind of any, you know, kind of any of these new fields over time. You know, but yeah, the other part is that you mentioned the nerd culture aspect to it, of any, you know, kind of any of these new fields over time. You know, but yeah, the other part is the, you mentioned this, the nerd culture aspect to it, which is, you know, we live, well, this is one of the things that's happened, right? We live in a world today where, you know, I don't know if nerds are cool, but like plenty of people have packaged
她是软件行业的缔造者之一。还有朱迪·埃斯特林（Judy Estrin），我的另一位朋友，是网络行业的缔造者之一，你知道的，就是将计算机联网。所以，他们确实是存在的。但毫无疑问，绝大多数，你知道的，绝大多数都是男性。是的，你看，这里面有一个因素，基本上，你知道的，可能跟你对任何其他这类新兴领域所能进行的性别讨论完全一样。你知道的，但另一个部分是，你提到了其中的书呆子文化（nerd culture）方面，关于任何这类新兴领域。你知道的，但另一个部分，你提到了这个，也就是其中的书呆子文化方面，你知道的，我们生活在这样一个世界里，好吧，这是发生的事情之一，对吧？我们今天生活在这样一个世界里，你知道的，我不知道书呆子（nerds）是否很酷，但有大量的人把
up nerd energy and figured out how to sell it. And then nerds have figured out how to start companies and build products and, you know, from time to time get rich on this stuff. And then nerds have figured out how to start companies and build products and, you know, from time to time, get rich on this stuff. And so, you know, there's a, you know, there's a status hierarchy and a sort of a success of life that, that sort of nerds have had sort of developed over the last 30 or 40 years that probably didn't exist before that. And so, yeah, there was, there was definitely a component to that. I think, I think, you you know i think the homebrew computer club would have been thrilled uh more women showed up to one of the meetings yeah well they may be not known what to say yes so so so we we have um we've got the pc we've got this kind of incredible concentration
书呆子能量打包，并弄清楚了如何将其变现。然后书呆子们又弄清楚了如何创办公司、打造产品，并且，你知道的，不时地靠这些东西发财。然后书呆子们又弄清楚了如何创办公司、打造产品，并且，你知道的，不时地靠这些东西发财。所以，你知道的，有一种状态等级制度和一种生活成功学，这种成功学是书呆子们在过去30到40年里发展起来的，在这之前可能并不存在。所以，是的，这里面绝对有这样一个因素。我想，我想，你知道的，我认为“自制电脑俱乐部”（Homebrew Computer Club）会非常激动，呃，有更多的女性出现在他们的某次聚会上。是的，好吧，她们可能不知道该说些什么。是的，所以，所以我们，我们有——我们有了PC，我们有了这种不可思议的集中——
of of first american and then global talent concentrated um south of the south of san francisco um and then you've got the internet so what is this what's the significance of the internet how does the internet take off and kind of that's a big question i know but but but i know you are the one man i can ask this question to and know that you won't be bullshitting when you answer well so the internet you know, so like a lot of the tech industry, so the internet starts with a story of basically military research, right? So the internet starts with a generation of research starting in the 1950s. And the literal origins, right, of it were nuclear command and control networks, right? Which is, you know, so you're the United States in 1950s, you're, you know, you're barking on the Cold War.
首先是美国人才，然后是全球人才，集中在——呃，旧金山南部——然后你有了互联网。那么，互联网的意义何在？互联网是如何腾飞的？这算是一个大问题，我知道，但——但——但我知道你是我能问这个问题并确信你回答时不会瞎扯的唯一一个人。好吧，所以互联网，你知道的，就像很多科技行业一样，互联网最初的故事基本上是军事研究，对吧？所以互联网始于20世纪50年代开始的一代研究。它的字面起源，对吧，是核指挥和控制网络，对吧？也就是说，你知道的，如果你是20世纪50年代的美国，你正在，你知道的，卷入冷战。
You've got these nuclear missiles and silos all over the country, you know, and on submarines and on aircraft and so forth. And you have to have a control system. But of course, the problem with nuclear command and control is what happens if there's a nuclear war and your command and control system gets knocked out. Right. And so then you can never, you know, your your your counterstrike ability is lost. And then, you know, the game theory says, you know, the minute that happens, the minute the other side knows they can take out your command and control system, then the game theory of nuclear war says they have to launch the first strike immediately because that's the chance. So this is like, you know, this is one of the biggest kind of highest tension issues in the military technology space. Then, so it's basically how do you build a network? How do you build a computer network that can withstand a nuclear war? Well, and so the key principle became how do you route around damage, right?
你全国各地都有这些核导弹和发射井，你知道的，还有潜艇、飞机等等。你必须有一个控制系统。但是，当然，核指挥 and 控制系统的问题在于，如果爆发核战争，你的指挥和控制系统被摧毁了，会发生什么。对吧。然后你就永远无法，你知道的，你的反击能力就丧失了。然后，你知道的，博弈论指出，你知道的，一旦发生这种情况，一旦对方知道他们可以摧毁你的指挥 and 控制系统，那么核战争的博弈论就表明他们必须立即发动第一打击，因为这就是机会。所以这就像是，你知道的，这是军事技术领域中最大、张力最高的问题之一。那么，这基本上就是：你如何构建一个网络？你如何构建一个能够经受核战争考验的计算机网络？好吧，关键原则就变成了：你如何绕过损坏进行路由？对吧？
And so if one node of the network is taken out, you know, how can you still get a message from point A to point B? And that led to this idea of packet switching, which is the basis of the modern Internet. That then gets commercialized starting in the 1960s by a whole series of companies, including my friend Judy. And then, you know, subsequently, the federal government funds this project in the 1980s called the NSFNet, National Science Foundation. And they basically pay for the first kind of high-speed broadband internet in the way that we don't understand it. It links together a whole bunch of research universities. And then, you know, basically by the late 1980s,
因此，如果网络的一个节点被摧毁了，你知道的，你如何仍然能够将消息从A点传送到B点？这就催生了分组交换（packet switching）的概念，这也是现代互联网的基础。随后，从20世纪60年代开始，这项技术被包括我的朋友朱迪在内的一系列公司商业化。然后，你知道的，随后的20世纪80年代，联邦政府资助了这个名为NSFNet（国家科学基金会网络）的项目。他们基本上资助了我们现在所不理解的最初的高速宽带互联网。它将一大批研究型大学连接在了一起。然后，你知道的，基本上到了20世纪80年代末，
you know, you have kind of the internet up and running in its modern form, but it's very contained to, you know, a relatively small set of users who are very technically sophisticated, you know, basically either at major research universities or military defense labs, or big companies of different kinds. And then, you know, things kind of rolled along for a while in that mode. And then, of course, you know, more famously, starting in the early 90s, you know, the internet became a consumer medium. And of course then of course, you know, more, more famously starting in the early nineties, you know, the internet became a consumer medium. And of course that was, you know, that was the big breakthrough kind of in 93, 94. And then, you know, the rest is more well-known. And you talked about, what was it? Eternal September? Eternal September. So,
你知道的，互联网已经以其现代形式建立并运行起来了，但它非常局限于，你知道的，一小部分用户，他们技术非常娴熟，你知道的，基本上要么在顶尖研究型大学或军事国防实验室，要么在各种大公司里。然后，你知道的，事情就那样以这种模式运转了一段时间。然后，当然，你知道的，更广为人知的是，从90年代初开始，你知道的，互联网变成了一种消费媒介。当然，然后，当然，你知道的，更广为人知的是，从90年代初开始，你知道的，互联网变成了一种消费媒介。当然，那是，你知道的，那是93、94年左右的重大突破。然后，你知道的，剩下的事情就更广为人知了。你谈到了，是什么来着？永恒九月？永恒九月。所以，
so there was this phenomenon. So the internet in retrospect, so the internet between call it, you know, the internet in its kind of modern form exists, I call it from the early 80s to now. From the early 80s to the early 90s, there was this about 10-year window, like I said, where it was this pretty esoteric thing. It was very hard to actually get on the internet. Your PC that you bought off the shelf did not have internet connectivity built in. It didn't have any of the software or hardware that you needed to be on the internet. So just normal people at home were not on the internet in those days. And so what would happen, basically,
所以曾有过这样一种现象。回顾过去，互联网——所以把互联网界定在——互联网以其现代形式存在，我称之为从80年代初到现在。从80年代初到90年代初，大约有10年的时间窗口，就像我说的，它是一个相当深奥难懂的东西。实际上很难接入互联网。你在商店里买的PC并没有内置互联网连接功能。它没有你上网所需的任何软件或硬件。所以在那些日子里，家里的普通人根本不上网。所以会发生什么呢，基本上，
so it was this sort of esoteric thing. And then it was a very sort of implicitly selected group of users who were these extremely technically sophisticated users. They were almost all working professionals with advanced engineering degrees, very intellectual, very engineering, you know, very engineering focused engineering culture. You know, so the Internet, like in the 1980s, basically, for example, you know, there was like no spam. You know, there was no fraud. There was no trolling. There was no misinformation. There was no hate speech.
所以它是一种相当深奥的东西。然后它是一群具有隐式筛选的用户，他们是这些技术极其娴熟的用户。他们几乎全都是拥有高级工程学位的在职专业人员，非常具有知识分子气息，非常工程化，你知道的，非常注重工程学的工程文化。你知道的，所以在20世纪80年代的互联网，基本上，举个例子，你知道的，根本没有垃圾邮件。你知道的，没有诈骗。没有网络钓鱼/恶意挑衅（trolling）。没有虚假信息。没有仇恨言论。
You know, it was like there was a utopian element to it, just sort of as a consequence of the people who could get on it. And then there was this phenomenon that these sort of internet old timers would know, which was the September phenomenon, which is basically every September, a new generation of, you know, undergrads or grad students or newly arrived employees at these places that had internet access would show up, right, you know, most famously, the undergrads, and they would be on the internet, and they would come kind of crashing into the internet, into the culture in September. And then it was sort of the job of the old time Internet people to kind of school the newbies on what they called netiquette. Right. Which was, you know, sort of proper behavior, you know, how to how to not be an asshole. And so it was sort of like every year is like, oh, you know, OK, another September, you know, pain in the butt.
你知道的，它有一种乌托邦式的色彩，这只是能够接触到它的人所带来的结果。然后有这样一种现象，互联网的老手们都会知道，那就是“九月现象”，也就是基本上每年九月，新一代的，你知道的，本科生、研究生，或者这些接入互联网的机构里新来的员工都会出现，对吧，你知道的，最著名的就是本科生，他们会接入互联网，然后在九月猛烈冲击互联网、冲击这种文化。然后，老资历的互联网人的工作就是给这些新人们恶补他们所谓的“网络礼仪”（netiquette）。对吧。也就是，你知道的，所谓的正确行为，你知道的，如何不去做一个混蛋。所以这有点像每年都在说：“哦，你知道的，好吧，又是一个九月，真是个让人头疼的家伙。”
It's been people who grouse about it. and then there was famously september 1993 september 1993 um that was the moment when america online aol which was a totally disconnected online service time for consumer online services with you know whatever at the time i don't know at the time it was probably i don't know five million users or something but that was a lot at the time. AOL in one stroke put all whatever 5 million of their kind of normal people, users, onto the internet, like all at once. And that became known as Eternal September because that's basically when the pass of Connecticut blew up. That's basically when that original culture blew up. And that's basically when, as we say now, the normies took over.
人们一直在抱怨这个。然后就是著名的1993年9月，1993年9月，呃，那是美国在线（AOL）的时刻。美国在线是一个完全独立的在线服务，面向消费者在线服务，当时无论如何，我不知道，当时可能拥有，我不知道，500万用户什么的，但放在当时已经很多了。AOL一举将他们大约500万普通人用户，全部一下子涌入了互联网。这就成了著名的“永恒九月”，因为基本上就是在那时，网络礼仪的防线彻底崩溃了。基本上就是在那时，最初的文化彻底粉碎了。也就是基本上从那时起，正如我们现在所说的那样，普通人（normies）接管了。
And this is also when you entered the story, right, Mark? Yeah, that's right. It also coincided. It coincided. AOL was like a fireburst, you know, whatever, because it was this sudden, it's this huge kind of bolus of users who hit all at once. But yeah, the other thing that happened was that was when we were doing the web browser, and that's around the time when we started Netscape, and that's the time basically when we were at Netscape, like able to package up all of the components you needed to get on the internet,
这也是你进入这个故事的时候，对吧，马克？是的，没错。这也同时发生了。它同时发生了。AOL就像是一场大爆发，你知道的，管他呢，因为它是一次突然的、巨大的用户涌入，一下子全涌进来了。但，是的，发生的另一件事是，那正是我们正在开发网页浏览器的时候，那大约是我们创办网景（Netscape）的时候，那基本上就是我们在网景的时候，能够把上网所需的所有组件打包，
put them in a box, put it on the store shelf that you could just buy and get on the internet. And that's also when Microsoft and Apple and the PC companies started to build internet capabilities into the computers. And so that began the cascade that led to where we are today. So Eternal September is basically the, oh, my God, here they come, in perpetuity. Yeah, the orcs are at the gate. And then going back to you and the the browser so it's mosaic and then it's netscape and i suppose it's um it's an odd question because tom and i have done you know 80 whatever episodes about history but we've never done one with a kind of historical actor
把它们装进一个盒子里，放到商店的货架上，你只要买下来就能上网。这也是微软、苹果和PC公司开始将互联网功能内置到电脑中的时候。这就引发了一连串的连锁反应，最终造就了我们今天的现状。所以“永恒九月”基本上就是那种“哦，天哪，他们来了”的感觉，而且永无止境。是的，半兽人已经兵临城下了。然后回到你和那个浏览器——所以那是Mosaic，然后是Netscape。我想这是一个奇怪的问题，因为汤姆和我做过，你知道的，关于历史的80多期节目，但我们在播客中从来没有邀请过历史的亲历者，
in the podcast and i wonder were you conscious when you were, you know, launching Netscape, for example, that you were in effect making history, that millions upon millions of people were going to be using this to communicate, to change the way they talk to each other, they shopped, you know, to be able to change politics, it would change. I mean, did you have any sense of any of that? Or were you too absorbed in the kind of the technical process? Well, so first of all, you all, I'm from the Midwest. So even if I thought that, I could never admit that I thought that. So I would deny that all the way to my grave.
我在想，当你在推出Netscape时，例如，你是否意识到你实际上正在创造历史，数以百万计的人将使用它来交流，改变他们彼此交谈的方式、购物的方式，你知道的，能够改变政治，它将改变一切。我的意思是，你对此有什么感觉吗？还是说你太专注于那种技术过程了？好吧，首先，各位，我来自中西部。所以，即使我那样想，我也绝不能承认我有那样想过。所以我到死都会否认这一点。
But no, so the thing that's lost now in the history, which was a big deal then, and this repeats itself over and over again. So I think about this a lot. This was not obvious. It was not obvious at all at that time that the internet was something that normal people would ever use, that there was ever any point to the normal person being on the internet, or that the normal person would ever be able to figure out how to use the internet, or that it would ever get to be easy to use or any of these things. And in fact, it was quite the opposite. There was this wall of skepticism from, you know, what you might broadly call the establishment. And, you know, by the establishment, I mean, it was a wall of skepticism from, you know, the big companies, from the big,
但不是的，现在历史中丢失的一点是——当时这是一件大事，而且这事一再重演。所以我经常思考这个问题。这在当时并不是显而易见的。在那个时候，这一点绝对不是显而易见的：互联网是普通人会使用的东西；普通人上网有任何意义；普通人永远能够弄清楚如何使用互联网；或者它会变得易于使用，又或者是这些事情中的任何一件。事实上，情况恰恰相反。来自，你知道的，你可以宽泛地称之为建制派（establishment）的怀疑之墙横亘在那里。而且，你知道的，所谓建制派，我的意思是，这是一堵来自大公司、来自大型，
you know, telecom companies, from the big tech companies. You know, it was a wall of skepticism for sure from like, you know, Hollywood and the content industry, that they would ever put their content online. There was a wall of skepticism from the government that normal people would ever use this. I'll give you an example. One fun fact is commercial activity on the internet, which is to say anything involving money, which is to say anything including e-commerce, like the ability to buy something online, was technically illegal through 1993. Really? Goodness. It was technically not permitted by what were called the Internet Acceptable Use Policies,
你知道的，电信公司、大型科技公司的怀疑之墙。你知道的，毫无疑问，还有来自好莱坞和内容产业的怀疑之墙，他们怀疑自己是否会把内容放到网上。政府也存在一堵怀疑之墙，怀疑普通人是否会使用这个东西。我给你举个例子。一个有趣的事实是，互联网上的商业活动，也就是任何涉及金钱的事情，也就是任何包括电子商务的事情，比如在线购买东西的能力，直到1993年技术上都是非法的。真的吗？天哪。按照所谓的“互联网可接受使用政策”，技术上是不允许的，
the AUP, which was sort of the sort of agreement that you had to have to kind of get on the net at that time. And it was because, you know, the whole thing was up to that point was paid for by, you know, research, you know, federal research money. And so they just kind of took it for granted that obviously, it would be improper to use the results of federal research for commercial purposes. So, so this was this was not obvious. And in fact, there was this whole wave at the time, if you go back and read the press at the time, there was this whole wave that actually the future instead at the time was going to be what was called interactive television, or what became known as literally 500 channels. So the idea basically was
即AUP，这可以说是当时为了上网你必须签署的一种协议。这是因为，你知道的，到那时为止，整个东西都是由，你知道的，研究经费、联邦研究经费资助的。所以他们就理所当然地认为，很显然，将联邦研究的成果用于商业目的将是不正当的。所以，所以这不是显而易见的。事实上，当时有一整股潮流，如果你回过头去阅读当时的媒体报道，会发现有一整股潮流认为，当时的未来实际上将是所谓的“交互式电视”，或者也就是后来字面意义上被称为的“500个频道”。所以这个想法基本上是
you'd be able to watch 500 channels of TV and then interact, they had what they called interactivity, which meant you could order a pizza with your remote control. And so it was there, this very, the sort of world, the sort of all the people in power at that time kind of had this view that there was just basically going to be, you know, that the role of the consumer, there's actually, right, the role of the consumer, the role of the individual is to be a couch potato, right, is to be a passive recipient, right, of content created by big companies to sit on the couch, absorb, you know, and by the way, there's some truth to this, right? You know, here we are with Netflix, you know, sit on the couch, absorb all this stuff. And then, you know, every once in a while, it's like to, you know, either buy a pizza, or maybe I'll drop off some toilet paper, stuff like that. This idea that individual users at scale were going to be
你将能够观看500个电视频道，然后进行互动，他们称之为“互动性”，这意味着你可以用遥控器点披萨。所以它是存在的，这个非常——当时掌权的所有人都有这样一种观点，即基本上将会有，你知道的，消费者的角色——实际上，对吧，消费者的角色，个人的角色就是做一个“沙发土豆”（couch potato），对吧，做一个大公司创造的内容的被动接受者，对吧，坐在沙发上，吸收，你知道的，顺便说一句，这也有一定道理，对吧？你知道的，我们现在有了Netflix，坐在沙发上，吸收所有这些东西。然后，你知道的，每隔一段时间，就像是去，你知道的，要么买个披萨，或者也许我去拿点卫生纸，诸如此类的事情。这种认为规模化的单个用户将成为
part of a truly interactive network where they were going to be able to contribute just as much as they consumed, right? And then, you know, you know, to, know, you know, you know, taking us up to the day, you know, some sort of massive impact on social media, the idea that, you know, you'd have all these people contributing their contributing their thoughts, whether you want to hear them or not like that. That was just viewed as like, just like, that was just crazy. Like people just were like that. That's just completely crazy talk. And so, so what we knew was that the internet worked for the people who were already on it and that it worked much better for those people than i think a lot of kind of normal people were understanding at that point and then i just here's here's what i never understood i never understood i mentioned the
一个真正的互动网络的一部分的想法，在这个网络中，他们将能够像消费一样进行贡献，对吧？然后，你知道的，你知道的，你知道的，把我们带到今天，你知道的，对社交媒体产生的某种巨大影响，这种想法，你知道的，你会拥有所有这些人贡献他们的想法，不管你想不想听，就像那样。这在当时被视为就像是——那简直太疯狂了。人们只会觉得那种说法完全是疯话。所以，所以我们知道的是，互联网对那些已经在使用它的人来说是管用的，而且它对那些人的运作效果，比我认为当时很多普通人所理解的要好得多。然后我只是——这里是——这是我从未理解的地方，我从未理解——我提到了
internal september there was another side to the september phenomenon which is so i was an undergrad at the university of illinois the entire campus was wired for broadband it was on the internet you can see the whole thing um but the assumption was when you graduated you would stop using it right like you would just like stop using it you you would be on email until you graduated then you're off email right and you and i was like well that doesn't make any sense and so i i think the the honest answer is you could squint and you could kind of say okay you know like forget for a moment whether or not this will take among the broader population but like if it does like what would that mean and how big could this get?
永恒九月。九月现象还有另一面，那就是——所以我是伊利诺伊大学的一名本科生，整个校园都铺设了宽带，接入了互联网，你可以看到整个系统，呃，但当时的假设是，当你毕业时，你就会停止使用它，对吧？就像你毕业后就会停用一样，你在毕业前一直使用电子邮件，然后毕业后你就不再使用电子邮件了。当时我想，嗯，这说不通啊。所以我想，诚实的回答是：你可以眯起眼睛去看，然后你基本上可以说，好吧，你知道的（暂时先不管这是否会在更广泛的人群中流行开来），但如果它真的流行了，那意味着什么？这能发展到多大？
And you could squint and you could see that because you can see those behaviors, but it was still a big conceptual leap that this would be mainstream. Mark, I mean, as, as someone who wasn't an engineer, who, who had no technical sophistication or ability whatsoever, I, for what it's worth, I remember in 1989, the autumn, I was at Oxford and there was a friend from California and he had one of those small Macs, you know, which I found revelatory. But the other thing that he showed me that I also remember being revelatory was a copy of William Gibson's Neuromancer, which had come out in 1984
你可以眯起眼睛去看，然后你能看到这一点，因为你能看到那些行为，但这仍然是一个巨大的概念飞跃，即这会成为主流。马克，我的意思是，作为一个不是工程师、毫无技术造诣或能力的人，无论这算什么，我记得在1989年的秋天，我在牛津大学，有一个来自加州的朋友，他有一台那种小型Mac，你知道的，我觉得这极具启示意义。但他向我展示的另一件我也记得极具启示意义的东西，是一本威廉·吉布森（William Gibson）的小说《神经漫游者》（Neuromancer），该书出版于1984年，
and described something called cyberspace and described it, you know, this consensual hallucination that you went online and you experienced it. And I remember through the 90s, never buying into this idea that the internet was something like, you know, CB radio or something, because I had this image of it being the future that had actually been written in 1984 of all years. And I wonder, am I unusual in that? Or do you think the fact that the internet came with this sense, trailing clouds of science fiction with it, this sense that it was making the future was always there, even before the internet had actually kind of gone mainstream?
书中描述了一种叫做“赛博空间”（cyberspace）的东西，并将其描述为，你知道的，你上网时经历的一种共识幻觉。我记得在整个90年代，我从未接受过这种观点，即互联网类似于CB无线电（公民波段无线电）之类的东西，因为我对它的印象是一个在1984年（无论如何都是这个年份）就已经被书写下来的未来。我想知道，我在这一点上很不寻常吗？还是说你认为，互联网从一开始就带有这种感觉，伴随着科幻小说的阴云，这种它正在创造未来的感觉一直都在，甚至在互联网真正变得主流之前就已经存在了？
Yeah, that's right. I think that's right. I think, yeah, there was for sure a threat of science fiction. By the way, there was also a threat of kind of gone mainstream yeah that's right i think that's right i think you know yeah there was for sure a threat of science fiction by the way there was also a threat of kind of what you might call pop science where people were talking about these things like the you know there there had been this wave of enthusiasm in the 80s around what were called bbss which were kind of these kind of you know these dial-up services that individual users were offering other other services uh to other users um yeah there was there was you know various yeah there were various kinds of movies and TV shows through that era. There was a huge boom, huge interest in the early 80s. In America,
是的，没错。我认为是这样的。我认为，是的，科幻小说的一缕线索肯定是存在的。顺便说一句，还有一缕——变得主流。是的，这就是正确的。我认为，你知道的，是的，科幻小说的一缕线索肯定是存在的。顺便说一句，还有一缕你可能会称之为大众科学的线索，人们在讨论这些事情，比如，你知道的，在80年代曾有过一阵热情浪潮，围绕着被称为BBS（公告牌系统）的东西，它们是那种，你知道的，个人用户向其他用户提供其他服务的拨号服务，呃，是的，在那一时期，你知道各种，呃，有各种各样的电影和电视节目。在80年代初，曾有过巨大的热潮，巨大的兴趣。在美国，
there were these TV shows like Knight Rider and Airwolf and so forth that really kind of glamorized this sort of really advanced computer technology. And so yeah, there was a lot of that. It was present in the culture. By the way, the most amazing thing about Neuromancer, which I highly recommend people read if they haven't, because it was very influential, and it was also influential on me, but William Gibson, the author, famously had not used a computer, refused to use a computer, and wrote that novel on a typewriter.
有《霹雳游侠》（Knight Rider）和《飞狼》（Airwolf）等电视节目，它们真的将这种非常先进的计算机技术美化了。所以，是的，有很多这样的东西。它存在于文化之中。顺便说一句，《神经漫游者》最了不起的地方在于——如果人们还没读过的话，我强烈建议去读读，因为它极具影响力，对我也很有影响——但威廉·吉布森，这位作者，有个著名的事实：他当时没有用过电脑，拒绝使用电脑，并且是用打字机写出了那部小说。
That's amazing. Maybe that means you can see more clearly if you're not, if you're viewing it as a pure outsider, which he was. Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly. Exactly. Right. So the Internet is up and running and then you start to get social media. So how big a change is that? Well, that's the network, isn't it?
这太惊人了。也许这意味着如果你不是其中一员，如果你把它当作一个纯粹的局外人来审视（他确实是），你能看得更清楚。是的，是的，是的，完全正确。完全正确。对。所以互联网已经建立并运行起来了，然后你开始拥有社交媒体。那么，这算是一个多大的变化？嗯，这就是网络，不是吗？
I mean, you mentioned network already, the word a few times. And I think, I mean, I don't know if you agree, Mark, but is it a new, completely new kind of network, social media? Yeah. So the basic mechanics behind social media are very old. They actually, the total prehistory here that goes actually back to the 1950s, there was a computer system actually at the University of Illinois in the 1950s called PLATO, P-L-A-T-O. You guys will appreciate the name. And it was actually an interactive multi-user computer system in the 1950s that they built basically entirely by hand. You know, it was very crude by obviously our standards, but it had, you know, the minute they had it up and running, they had different, you know, kind of nodes that were together. And then the minute they did that, they had messaging happening between the nodes. And then they had, you know, multiplayer games, and they had you could put, you know,
我的意思是，你已经提到了网络这个词好几次了。我想，我的意思是，我不知道你是否同意，马克，但社交媒体是一种全新、完全新型的网络吗？是的。所以社交媒体背后的基本机制非常古老。实际上，这里有一个完整的史前史，甚至可以追溯到20世纪50年代，20世纪50年代伊利诺伊大学实际上有一个名为PLATO（普拉托）的计算机系统，P-L-A-T-O。你们会欣赏这个名字的。它实际上是20世纪50年代的一个交互式多用户计算机系统，基本上完全是手工建造的。你知道的，按我们的标准来看它非常简陋，但它确实拥有，你知道的，一旦它建立并运行起来，它就有了不同的，你知道的，连接在一起的节点。然后一旦他们做到了这一点，节点之间就开始有了消息传递。然后他们就有了，你知道的，多人游戏，而且你还可以放置，你知道的，
status messages and kind of say, you know, I'm out of the office, or I'm, you know, available to chat, or I'm hungry, or whatever. And so that, you know, they have the rudiments right up front, you know, the 1960s, multi user computer computing kind of went a little bit more broad. Again, the first thing you did when you network computers together, even in a small environment, even like in an office environment was you started to have messaging and these kinds of, you know, kind of rudimentary social features. And then, you know, like I said, you had in the 80s, you had this boom, even before kind of the Internet would be in stream, you had this boom and what were called these bulletin board systems or BBSs where people would log in and, you know, have these, you know, they would have literally bulletin boards, they'd have forums, you know, and there would be everything from classified ads to, you know, dating applications to, you know, to, you know, to the ability to chat with other users. And then, you know, AOL, CompuSphere, Prodigy were these kind of commercialized BBSs. They had a lot of these capabilities.
状态消息，并且可以，你知道的，说“我不在办公室”、“我，你知道的，可以聊天”、“我饿了”诸如此类的话。所以，你知道的，他们一开始就掌握了基本要素，你知道的，20世纪60年代，多用户计算变得更加广泛。同样，当你把计算机联网时，你做的第一件事，甚至在一个小环境中，比如在办公室环境中，就是开始进行消息传递和这些，你知道的，这种简陋的社交功能。然后，你知道的，就像我说的，你在80年代经历了一次繁荣，甚至在互联网普及之前，你就经历了一次繁荣，这就是所谓的公告牌系统或BBS，人们可以在那里登录，并进行这些，你知道的，他们会有真正的公告牌，他们会有论坛，你知道的，从分类广告到，你知道的，约会应用，再到，你知道的，与其他用户聊天的能力，应有尽有。然后，你知道的，AOL、CompuServe、Prodigy就是这些商业化的BBS。它们拥有许多这样的功能。
And so, like, there was, you know, a lot of these, like, the general pattern that I've seen is, like, for any of these things that, like, break through to the mass market in tech, it's like there's always, like, a 40 or 50 year kind of back history. And sort of the ideas are being incubated. Social media, as we know it today, you know, kind of broke out. It actually started in the late nineties. You know, there was Friendster in around 2000, there was MySpace in around 2002. And then, you know, Facebook kind of hit the scene in 2004, 2005. You know, there were a couple of things that really kind of catalyzed the sort of massive social networking boom starting in the mid 2000s, you know, really with like Facebook and LinkedIn and Twitter. I would say two big things is one is just that that happened to be when the consumer Internet actually kind of became mainstream. It was actually an interesting historical thing because, you know, the 90s were the quote unquote dot com boom.
所以，就像是，你知道的，这里有许多这样的东西，我所看到的总体模式是，对于科技领域中任何这些突破并进入大众市场的技术来说，总是有着大约40到50年的历史积淀。这些想法正在被孵化。我们今天所知道的社交媒体，你知道的，开始爆发了。它实际上始于90年代末。你知道的，2000年前后有Friendster，2002年前后有MySpace。然后，你知道的，Facebook在2004、2005年左右登上了历史舞台。你知道的，有几件事情真正催生了2000年代中期开始的大规模社交网络热潮，你知道的，确实是以Facebook、LinkedIn和Twitter为代表。我想说两件大事：一是恰好那个时候消费者互联网实际上变成了主流。这实际上是一个有趣的历史现象，因为，你知道的，90年代是所谓的“网络泡沫（dot-com boom）”。
But even most Americans were not on the Internet in the 1990s. Right. It was still a minority thing to even do. And it wasn't really until the mid 2000s that you started to have kind of a tip where a majority of the population actually got on the Internet. And that was also around the same time that broadband actually became a thing. And so there was just this kind of moment there where you kind of hit critical mass on the users. And then the other thing was, you know, the sort of other just gigantic, I think, innovation in retrospect, in particular around Facebook, which had a huge impact on things, was Mark Zuckerberg was the first internet entrepreneur who basically, you know, stood up with a straight face and said, people are going to use their real names
但甚至在20世纪90年代，大多数美国人也并没有上网。对吧。上网甚至仍然是少数人的事。直到2000年代中期，你才真正开始迎来一个转折点，即大多数人口实际上都接入了互联网。这也是宽带真正兴起的大致同一时期。所以当时刚好有这样一个时刻，你让用户达到了临界点。然后另一件事是，你知道的，另一个巨大无比的创新，我认为回过头来看，特别是围绕Facebook，它对事情产生了巨大的影响，马克·扎克伯格是第一个互联网企业家，他基本上，你知道的，一本正经地站出来说，人们将在互联网上使用他们的真实姓名，
on the internet, right? And, right, which is really interesting because like basically before that and this is again kind of maybe lost history now but like before that the assumption was you could use the internet all day long but the one thing you would never do is use your real name right um you would always use a number or a guy or what is called a screen name or you know whatever a login id or something or a you know a pseudonym of some kind and you would basically do that well because because everybody knew, right?
对吧？而且，对吧，这非常有趣，因为在此之前——这同样可能是现在已经失落的历史——但在那之前，大家的假设是你可以整天使用互联网，但你绝对不会做的一件事就是使用你的真实姓名，对吧？呃，你总是会使用一个数字、一个代号，或者所谓的网名（screen name），或者你知道的，某个登录ID之类的东西，或者某种化名，你基本上就会这么做，好吧，因为每个人都知道，对吧？
Everybody's like, the internet's not the real world. Like, it's this other different thing. You know, it's this kind of weird thing. It's kind of nerdy and weird. By the way, you know. Dungeons and Dragons, kind of. Yeah. And then, by the way, it's the Wild West.
每个人都觉得，互联网不是真实世界。它是个完全不同的东西。你知道的，这是个诡异的东西。它有点书呆子气，而且很诡异。顺便说一句，你知道的。有点像《龙与地下城》。对。然后，顺便说一句，这里是蛮荒西部。
You know, and this was a term at the time. A lot of the press coverage in the 1990s were the internet is the wild West. And, you know, and at that point it was like, you know, there are criminals in the wild West, they're bad guys, you know, there's spam and there's, you know, fraud. And there was this whole, like one of the big things we had to get early, early in the, in the 90s people comfortable with was like basically the idea of ever
你知道的，这也是当时的常用术语。20世纪90年代的大多数新闻报道都说互联网是蛮荒西部。而且，你知道的，在那个时候，就像是，你知道的，蛮荒西部有罪犯，有坏人，你知道的，有垃圾邮件，还有欺诈。有这样一整套东西，比如我们在90年代初必须让人们尽早适应的一大事情，基本上就是这个概念——
basically paying for anything online. And, and, and, you know, credit cards were kind of the way people paid for things online. And um you know the idea of putting your credit card number on the internet was like a very scary thing for a long time and so it's another one of these things where like you know you might get stolen your identity there's a whole rush of panic around identity theft or identity might get stolen and ruin your life if people find out who you were so so yeah it was it was like everybody put a mask on um and then you know it's one of these generational things where you know mark zuckerberg is you know was what uh he's probably what 15 it's probably 15 years younger than i am or something so um you know and he so he kind of
基本上就是在网上支付任何东西。而且，而且，你知道的，信用卡是人们在网上支付东西的方式。呃，你知道的，把你的信用卡号放在互联网上在很长一段时间里是一件非常可怕的事情。所以这是另一件这样的事情，就像是，你知道的，你的身份可能会被盗，围绕身份盗窃存在着一阵阵的恐慌，如果人们发现你是谁，你的身份可能会被盗并毁了你的生活。所以，是的，这就好像每个人都戴着面具。然后，你知道的，这是代际差异之一，你知道的马克·扎克伯格是，你知道的，他当时是什么——他可能比我小15岁左右，或者什么的。所以，呃，你知道的，当所有这些事情发生时，他正在90年代长大成人，对他来说，这就像是——这只是一种不同的心态，就像是“显而易见，这将成为日常生活的一部分，显而易见，这将是你一直在做的事情，呃，但显而易见，你应该代表你自己——这应该就是你，为什么不呢？”然后，你知道的，我认为这确实是转折点，因为在那个时候，突然之间，这就好像——就好像互联网从一个充满怪人的地方——所有这些，是的，所有这些，你知道的，这种，我不知道，某种奇怪的，我不知道，低端电子视频游戏之类的东西，里面跑着所有这些假
you know kind of came of age in the 90s as all this stuff was happening and to him it was just like oh it was just a different mentality it's like oh obviously this is going to be part of everyday life you know obviously this is going to be something that you do all the time um but just obviously you should represent yourself like it it should be you, like why wouldn't it be? And then that, you know, I think that was really the tipping point because at that point, then all of a sudden it was like, it was like the internet changed from like this land of weird, you know, all these, yeah, all these, you know, this, this sort of, I don't know, sort of weird, I don't know, low-end video game or something where you had all these kind of fake
人。突然之间，就像是，“哦，天哪，他们全都是我的朋友。”对吧？他们就在那里。对吧？然后，这就是巨大的突破。所以，汤姆，我从未上过Facebook。你上Facebook吗？我没有上Facebook。
people running around. All of a sudden it's like,, oh, my God, they're all my friends. Right? There they are. Right? And then that was the big breakthrough. So, Tom, I've never gone on Facebook. Are you on Facebook? I'm not on Facebook.
没有。没有。原因和我不用快克毒品（crack）一样。但这正是你不用《刺客信条》的原因。没错。我有一种非常容易上瘾的个性，我对所有这些事情都感到紧张。但在Facebook的案子里，它有点——我猜这是一种焦虑，担心——
No. No. For the same reason I'm not on crack. But that's your reason for not playing Assassin's Creed. Exactly. I have a very addictive personality personality and i'm nervous for all these things but also in the in the case of facebook it is kind of um i suppose a kind of nervousness about um having uh all my most intimate details singing off to california to be processed
将我所有最私密的细节发送到加州去处理。
yeah but this is coming from a man who live tweets his walks i know i know but that but that's that's that's the terrible thing. That's why I know that I should never go on Facebook and why I always vowed that I would never do a podcast. So there you go. So I think that's probably the perfect note on which to bring this episode to an end and to set up the second episode with Marc Andreessen
是的，但这可是一个会在直播中发推特记录自己散步的人说的话。我知道，我知道，但那——但那正是可怕的地方。这就是为什么我知道我永远不应该上Facebook，也是为什么我总是发誓我绝不做播客的原因。所以你看。所以我想这大概是一个完美的音符，以此为本集画上句号，并为与马克·德安德森的第二集做好铺垫，
where we will talk about social media, we'll talk about software eating the world and the kind of broader sense in which, how do we place this in the broadest context of history? How does this relate to printing and so on? And of course, to honour your commitment, your disregard for social media, we should be advertising it on Twitter, as we always do.
在第二集中，我们将讨论社交媒体，我们将讨论软件吞噬世界，以及更广泛意义上的问题：我们如何将这一切置于最宏大的历史背景中？这与印刷术等有什么关系？当然，为了兑现你的承诺，为了兑现你对社交媒体的漠视，我们应该像往常一样在Twitter上宣传它。
And I might even sign up to Facebook to do it. Very good. We'll see you next time for part two. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我甚至可能会为了做这件事去注册一个Facebook账号。非常好。我们下期节目再见，下集见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家单集、提前解锁、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。